A house divided
over military
and financial aid to Ukraine.
So brand new CNN reporting
reveals a growing chasm
among the GOP
as the war enters its second year
Some hard line Republicans
say the billions spent back in Ukraine
is a prime example of government waste.
And given their slim House majority,
it could be enough to complicate
or potentially
even block
additional funding down the road.
Joining us now to share their reporting
and their insights, CNN's M.J.
Lee, CNN's Isaac
over to Mitchell
of the Atlanta Journal-Constitution.
And CNN's Lauren Fox.
So the House Republicans, you report
it's a minority,
but it's a vocal minority
who say America first.
What are we doing
Where's the money going?
Yeah, and it's been a dramatic
split screen this week.
While you've had the president
visiting Ukraine,
you have had a lot of these House
Republicans arguing
he shouldn't be there in the first place.
He should be back in the United States.
So I think one of the biggest chasms
that you're starting to see right now
is just fatigue about
why is the US spending money at all.
And it's a real big difference
between the leadership
and some of these rank and file members.
You have people like Mitch McConnell
who are going to go out there and argue
all day
long on Fox News
that this is an important issue
for the Republican base.
Then you have people like Kevin McCarthy,
who's going to have to
contend with some of those conservatives
like Matt Gates, who has a resolution
asserting American fatigue
over giving Ukraine
financial aid for this war.
Kevin McCarthy
said he did not support that resolution.
But he also doesn't support
a blank check.
And that leads to a lot of question marks
as this fight on Capitol Hill
really intensifies
over spending over the next
several months.
What does that mean
for the future of Ukraine?
And this isolationist movement
is growing in the republic
where it's not new, but it is growing.
And you see, it's in
your noteworthy
many House Republicans said,
what is President Biden doing there?
The last few days,
they did not seem to question.
While their own House Foreign Affairs
Committee Chairman,
Mike McFaul
was there, leading
a bipartisan delegation of House members,
he was in Kyiv right after
President Biden.
I didn't see any tweets saying
why isn't he back in Texas?
Why isn't he at the border?
They seem to have forgotten that part.
It's interesting, though,
because over in the Senate,
most Republicans in the Senate
think this is a fight
the United States must be
and most Republicans in the Senate.
This is an area where they say
President Biden is doing the right thing.
They might even want him to do more.
Shelley Moore, Capitol,
Republican of West Virginia.
Maybe they aren't
getting the same information,
she says of House members.
I think maybe
there are more people over there
who view it as an enhancement of war,
where we see it as protection of freedom.
That's what President Biden
has been saying,
that if you give Putin Ukraine,
what's to stop him
from going into Estonia, Latvia, Moldova,
those group of nine countries
we just showed?
Yeah.
And I think what
the more seasoned
Republicans, the Republicans
who've been around,
we have to remember the House,
especially this
new kind of more empowered, far right
contingent of the House
has not been around a really long time.
But those senators who had say,
if you empower Putin and quite frankly,
even this rhetoric around
withdrawing US funding
is something
that can further empower
Putin to say, hey, I can stay the race
and hope to wait out the US
and then bide my time.
And I think
what we're hearing from senators
is that you can't let that happen.
The question
is, will the House
that new Republican
majority start
standing in the way of further U.S.
support for the Ukraine?
And what makes it all
the more interesting is
as we head
into the presidential cycle, it's
not just a House Republican
or even an internal House
Republican divide.
You see it
playing out on the campaign trail
among declared
and likely soon to be Republican
presidential candidates
the war in Ukraine.
It's more than just about Ukraine.
This is a war about freedom
and it's a war
we have to win
They have effectively
a blank check policy
with no clear strategic
objective identified.
And these things can can escalate.
And I don't think it's in our interest
to be getting
into a proxy war with China.
Is this a fight?
President Biden
wants to have on the campaign trail,
or is there any concern
at the White House
that if this is a either
or campaign issue, it undermines
the effort in Congress?
Well, look,
I would say that
I think the last 72 hours have shown
what a tough hand
Republicans have to play in many ways.
Right.
We've had this president,
who has made a dangerous trip into a war
zone, has been sticking his finger
in the eye of Vladimir Putin
and standing
next to an international hero.
That being Volodymyr Zelensky,
American voters
like seeing a president
who looks strong on
the international world stage,
particularly heading into a war zone.
On such an unprecedented trip.
And Republicans
want to sort of make something political
out of something
that is very challenging
for them to deal with.
The imagery of the president
making this trip has been
something challenging
for Republicans to deal with.
But I think, you know, Lauren,
you make a really good point about how
this isn't
really the majority of Republicans
in the Republican Party.
In large part,
they are supportive of continuing
to fight against Vladimir Putin.
But I think someone like Kevin McCarthy,
he hasn't really made clear
what exactly
he means when he says
there's not going to be a blank check
made out to Ukraine.
Pick your cycle.
Presidential primaries often
settle debates in parties.
Bill Clinton
was the different kind of Democrat.
George W Bush wanted
compassionate conservatism.
Donald Trump rewrote
the rules of Republican politics.
Will this debate be settled?
Well, look,
what we're going to is already
Nikki Haley is saying that
if we don't continue in the war with
and for Ukraine,
then that will lead to World War Three.
Donald Trump is saying
if we do continue it,
that will lead to World War Three.
That's where the Republican Party
is divided on this.
And then you get into all the House
dynamics.
All this is going to be something
where you have a lot of Republicans
who are facing
this isolation is
the idea is also budget ideas,
but trying to figure out
how they attack Joe Biden
and how they make Biden the bad guy here.
As MJ said,
he through the imagery of this week,
made that a little bit tricky for them.